this video is kindly sponsored by
fabulous
the number one self-care app to help you
build better habits
and achieve your goals hey 42 here
if you're fond of reading books about
the sea you might have read the one
about a sperm whale called
moby dick who's known to eat semen
and no giggling to yourself just because
i said sperm and
dick and semen in the same sentence
we're all mature adults here i just
can't handle
infantile humor herman melville's
legendary novel about the great white
whale was published in 1851 which
doesn't seem like a long time ago but in
maritime terms
it was another era altogether an age
when the sea was full of monsters
unlike today when the worst you might
expect on a ship is
bad sunburn and a shortage of rum the
sailors of yesteryear
had proper things to worry about on the
6th of august 1848
around the time melville was writing
about giant spunk whales
captain macquarie of the hms daedalus
along with several of his officers and
crew
spotted a massive serpent in the ocean
beside
their ship as they sailed from the cape
of good hope to saint helena
reports from the captain and seven of
his colleagues
estimated the serpent was around 20
meters long
with at least a metre of its giant
snake-like head traveling above the
water
less than a year later a similar report
was published in the illustrated london
news
with details of a serpent that matched
the same description
being cited off the coast of portugal if
you want to avoid those deep-sea
beasties lady you best be in good shape
and for that you need a good healthy
daily routine
so if you're anything like me you've
probably been finding it tough
spending a little longer cooped up
indoors the past year
than you'd ideally like to be i for one
have definitely developed some bad
habits
like substituting my daily intake of
water
for something somewhat higher in proof
and it's best we leave it there and i've
had way too many late nights
i've taken the decision to try to be
healthier and take care of myself
so my body takes care of me in the
future
so i'm using fabulous to add structure
to my day
and start to factor in time to head out
for a walk
or to read a few pages of that book that
i started six months ago
and most importantly start to eat and
drink healthier
i can tell you i'm drinking
significantly more water
every day since using fabulous it works
fabulous makes it easy for anyone to
develop and stick to healthy habits
thanks to science-backed daily routines
as a result
you'll feel healthier fulfilled and more
productive
i know i do fabulous is different from
other self-improvement
apps firstly it allows you to go at your
own pace
unlike other self-development apps
fabulous is gentler
more rewarding more fun and has a more
supportive approach
meaning you don't have to beat yourself
up if you don't hit one of your daily
tasks
it's also 100 personalized tailored to
your own needs
fabulous provides schedules tasks and
reminders
specific to you it's like having a
personal life coach
in your pocket i know that fabulous has
been a positive impact on my routine and
general well-being
and it could do the very same for you
you can find out more about the fabulous
app by clicking on the link in the
description below
you'll also receive a free week's trial
and
up to 25 off a fabulous subscription
so join me and kickstart your journey
today
to you and i these stories may seem
ridiculous
but at that point in history the natural
sciences were still young
charles darwin wouldn't publish on the
origin of species
for another 10 years or so and most
people had
little rational understanding of nature
and biology
it was normal for even the more educated
seagoing men like the captain
and officers to believe in sea monsters
in fact sailors from all cultures were
raised on a diet of
superstition and tales of terrifying
beasts of the ocean
then again sea monster was basically
just
a catch-all phrase which you could
roughly take to mean
big moving thing in the water we don't
recognize the sea serpent spotted by
captain mcwhorje and the men of the
daedalus for example
is likely to have been a sigh whale
there's nothing monstrous or mystical
about these beasts
but they're known to be skim feeding
specialists
meaning often all you see of them is the
upper jaw poking out above the water and
hey you have to admit it does look a bit
weird
another species thought to have been
responsible for a lot of
sea serpent stories is the giant oarfish
also rather quaintly known as the king
of herrings
these freaky creatures can grow to be 11
meters long
making them the longest bony fish on the
planet
and their brightly coloured crests give
them a distinctly
sea serpenty vibe again today
we know they're just regular old fish
but back before they were known to
science it's no surprise people thought
they were sea monsters it's also worth
remembering
we haven't exactly completed the marine
pokedex
even today several thousand new animals
are discovered every single year
and the 250 000 or so species we've put
a name to
so far is thought to be only around
ten percent of the true number and it
isn't just a small stuff we're yet to
collect
we discovered a new species of barley
and whale
not so different from the one that
played a prank on the crew of the
daedalus
just this year in the gulf of mexico
nowadays we have a new word to describe
monsters of the deep
leviathan but the term originates in the
old hebrew bible where it describes a
fire-breathing sea serpent
that could boil water with its breath in
ancient greek mythology
the doomed princess andromeda was
chained to a rock by her parents
as a sacrifice to a horrible sea
creature called cetus
this piece of work was so nasty no one
could really agree on what it looked
like
it was generally thought to be a
serpentine monster
though in some versions it had the head
of a greyhound
and the body of a dolphin which would be
weird enough to scare the crap out of
anyone luckily for
andromeda just before cetus arrived to
devour her
the hero perseus pitched up fell in love
with her
and set her free before killing the sea
freak
perseus assumed that stunt would gain
him enough brownie points to be able to
marry the woman he'd saved
but apparently her parents had already
promised andromeda to her uncle
geez who needs sea serpents when you've
got parents like that
of course perseus did what any love
struck lad would do
and slaughtered andromeda's uncle before
marrying the beauty
also tormenting the greeks was silla the
man-eating monster from homer's odyssey
at first glance she was a total catch a
beautiful woman from the waist up
but things were less pleasant below the
belt
and no i don't mean camel toe she had
12 tentacle-like legs and a cat's tail
with six dog's heads arranged around her
waist
she also had six long sneaky necks each
sporting a human head full of shark's
teeth
which she used to snatch sailors from
their ships as they passed the rocks she
lived on other ocean monsters from world
folklore include the umabozo in japan
a black phantom that rises from the calm
waters to pull sailors overboard
and drown them and the iron crown from
scotland
that's so big it could eat seven whales
in one
sitting without getting so much as a
stomachache even the european myth of
the mermaid is darker than you may think
it wasn't always a story of little
disney princesses or
daryl hannah from splash the original
mermaids would hypnotize
passing seafarers with their enchanting
singing
and mesmerizing looks luring them into
the water
before eating their flesh and no
not in a nice way but amongst the many
nightmarish tales of what awaits you at
sea
one beast in particular seems to crop up
across
cultures countries and traditions
more than any other a massive
octopus-like creature with lung
tentacles
capable of crushing entire ships before
dragging them down to the watery depths
the aenu people of northern japan revere
a giant creature
called the akara komoi that apparently
lives in akura bay
on the island of hokkaido reaching up to
33 meters in length
the iku torso of finland lives in ohio
the land of all evil and while
some stories claim it resembles a giant
walrus
others paint it with huge suckered
tentacles and
dragon-like wings that grow when it's
angry
kind of reminds me of one of my exes
perhaps the most
famous eight tentacled monster of the
deep is the kraken from norse mythology
it's one of the biggest animals ever
imagined by humans
two and a half kilometers in
circumference with a mouth the size of a
coastal bay
the kraken hunted the seas between
norway greenland and iceland
either by attacking ships directly or
creating an
inescapable whirlpool that would drag
them underwater
the history of the cracking goes back to
an account written in 1180
by kings verde of norway whilst recorded
sightings of the beast go all the way
back
to a 13th century norwegian text with a
title
that i'm going to spare from
pronunciation-based execution
yeah which includes a detailed
description of a mammoth creature
that could eat an entire ship's crew in
one gulp
and was capable of swallowing wales
whole
and to give you an idea of just how much
the world has changed in the last few
hundred years
even as recently as the 18th century the
kraken was getting some limelight
in mankind's best natural history books
famous swedish naturalist carl linnaeus
included the kraken as a species of
cephalopod mollusk
in the first edition of his
groundbreaking systema natura
the first book of modern biological
classification
published in 1735. up until that point
the description of the kraken had varied
a bit
sometimes even showing up as a colossal
crab
but after cunning glennaeus published
his book
pretty much everyone changed their
definition to something along the lines
of
terrifying big octopus type thing in
later years the author was
embarrassed about having believed in sea
monsters and removed the kraken from
future editions
of sistema natura a couple of decades
later
eric pontoffadon bishop of bergen
wrote what he called the first attempt
at a natural history of norway
in which he shared the gospel truth
about the kraken
including the fact it was the size of
multiple land masses
submerged entire ships with the flick of
a tentacle
and attracted particularly brave
norwegian fishermen
because it was usually surrounded by
swarms of fish feeding on its large
volumes of excrement
importantly though pontopodon mentions a
time in 1680
when a young kraken washed ashore and
died near a town
called al starhook this could be one of
the first
clues to the true identity of the
mythical creature
the kraken has featured in works of
fiction like jules verne's 20 000
leagues under the sea
and tennyson's poem called wait for it
the kraken it's also made its way into
modern popular culture
free films like the pirates of the
caribbean but
to date it seems nobody has taken
advantage of the golden opportunity
to give their depiction of the kraken
the name phil
phil mccracken anyone no
just me these days no scientist with a
shred of professional credibility claims
the mythological kraken
is a real beast but we can assume the
story originated somewhere
in reality the question is what
animal is the legend based on one
candidate it's a giant pacific octopus
the largest of the octopus species and
one that's found in the kind of
cold water regions where sea monster
stories and homemade vodka
often originate but even with an arm
span of up to eight meters and a
reputation for snacking on small sharks
this animal doesn't quite make the
gargantuan grade
another potential beast is the giant
octopus
a theoretical animal that has no
official biological classification
because there has never been any proof
of its existence the main piece of
evidence that such a creature may roam
the seas
is claimed to be the saint augustine
monster a large blob-like carcass of an
unidentified creature
found washed up on the u.s coast near
saint augustine
florida in 1896 this is one of the first
recorded findings
of a globster which is the ridiculous
name people give to piles of decaying
unrecognizable organic matter that wash
upon beaches around the world
yes that's actually a thing most
globsters have proved to be bits of
whale carcasses
but the saint augustine monster has been
more difficult to categorize
with its strange shape and texture many
over the years believed this blob to be
the remains of some
gigantic form of octopus including some
scientists who conducted tests in the
70s and 80s
but in 1995 electron microscopy
and biochemical analysis seemed to show
once and for all
that the flesh did not belong to a
member of the octopus family
but was almost certainly the remains of
a whale
probably the entire skin of one so much
for octopus giganteus
there is however a real monstrously
large creature
that would have frightened the salty
chaffing pants off ancient mariners
the giant squid the first known
reference to this big chunk of calamari
dates back to 4 bc and aristotle who
spoke of a type of squid that was much
larger than others of its kind
pliny the elder also had a bit to say on
the matter in the 1st century a.d
describing a massive squid with arms 9
meters long
and a body weighing 320 kilograms
after that things went pretty quiet
apart from the occasional sighting of a
man-eating sea monster
until the 17th century when a carcass
found in iceland
became the oldest certified record of a
giant squid
it wasn't until 1857 that yapita's steam
strip
first classified the creature and even
today
sightings remain incredibly rare with
most of what we've learned having come
from specimens washed up on beaches
particularly in new zealand and
newfoundland
by the turn of the 21st century we still
did not have one photograph of a living
giant squid but that changed in 2002
when the first image of a live specimen
was caught on camera
at goshiki beach in japan in 2004 a
massive
8 meter character was photographed
hunting at 900 meters below the surface
off japan's ogasawa islands the first
moving images of a small specimen were
captured in 2006
and finally in 2012
a film crew from the discovery channel
and the japanese network
managed to lure a mature adult giant
squid
of about 10 meters in length and film it
feeding
for almost 25 minutes despite the
excitement around these photos
and film footage we still know bugger
all about these beasts
we know they live deep but we're not
exactly sure
how deep we don't really know how they
find a mate
how they hunt how long they live for
where they lay their eggs or how many
there are
we aren't even quite sure just how big
they can get
but extrapolation based on what we know
so far
suggests the biggest could be a frankly
absurd
25 meters long or more
though admittedly most of that is just
tentacle still
it isn't hard to imagine glimpses of
these deep sea monsters from the decks
of
ships could have spawned the kraken myth
but if that sounds like one scary squid
you'd better sit down because the giant
squid is actually kind of a weed
compared to its big brother
the imaginatively named colossal squid
only discovered in 1925 these
titans of the abyss are admittedly a
little shorter than their
giant siblings but they're much much
girthier the chodes of the squid
world if you will whilst the heaviest
giant squid are thought to come in at
around 275 kilograms
colossal squid are as much as three
times that weight
and they sport the largest eyes of any
animal on the planet
at roughly the size of a large human
head all the better to scare the crap
out of you with but whilst both giant
and colossal squid
look pretty fearsome they don't actually
represent the top of the food chain
as both are preyed on by moby dick and
his [ __ ] mates
in fact it's thought the environmental
pressure from sperm wales was the
evolutionary driver
behind the development of those
disturbing dinner plate
eyes you see thousands of meters down
where these guys live even giant eyes
aren't actually all that much use next
to no light makes it down that far
but the world's biggest peepers do help
these monstrous squid detect extremely
large shapes
for example the kind of super-sized
silhouettes owned by sperm whales
this deep-sea rivalry is often depicted
as a kind of battle of the titans
you might have seen the impressive
diorama of the two
in a fight to the death that hangs in
the museum of natural history in new
york
but in reality it's very much a
one-sided fight
in fact sperm whales eat these squid for
breakfast
both literally and figuratively a lot of
what we know about both giant and
colossal squid
comes from remains particularly their
mouthpieces
known as beaks found in the stomachs of
sperm whales
by some estimates colossal squid make up
as much as 75 percent
of the sperm whales diet by mass still
the squid are known to put up a fight on
the way down
because plenty of sperm whales have been
found covered in sucker marks
from both giant and colossal squid
colossal squid are also candidates to be
the inspiration for the kraken
but the giant squid is probably a better
fit
as colossal squid prefer to congregate
around the antarctic
and by congregate i mean socially
distant with miles of empty ocean
between them
to be honest we don't know if that's
true either
since we have no evidence of them in
their natural habitats
and none of them use instagram so whilst
there may not be any
real sea monsters left in our 21st
century oceans
for my money some of the regular old
animals down there
are almost as good thanks for watching